momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañero luís méndez
louis llegó el momento de hablar de un
tema que preocupa a todos porque tiene
que ver con los efectos del cambio
climático en el planeta así es andrés
durante los últimos días hemos visto que
hay mucha información respecto a este
tema y sobre todo por la particularidad
del impacto que está teniendo en la
economía mundial ya esto de acuerdo con
un informe de las naciones unidas tras
un estudio del suizo art institute el
cambio climático y en si el
calentamiento global podría afectar el
producto interno bruto mundial para el
año 2050 pero antes de revisar cuál
podría ser el impacto económico de los
países de un aumento de temperatura o
encima de los daños plenos al planeta
debemos informar que desde el siglo 19
aproximadamente los seres humanos han
generado un aumento en la temperatura
del planeta en 1,1 grados celsius esto
producto mayoritariamente de la quema de
carbón petróleo y gas para obtener
energía esta situación llevó a los
países en el año 2015 a establecer una
ruta para limitar el aumento de la
temperatura global y dejarla entre 15 y
2 grados celsius un compromiso asumido
por más de 190 países y al que se añadió
la unión europea este está dirigido a
reducir de forma sustancial las
emisiones mundiales de gases de efecto
invernadero
de acuerdo con el estudio dado a conocer
en junio por la organización de las
naciones unidas de cumplirse lo pactado
en el acuerdo de parís el mundo sufriría
una reducción de su producto interno
bruto en 42 por ciento para el año 2050
preguntas más extremo la perdida
rondaría alrededor del 18 1% esto a
nivel global pero el caso más grave se
estaría presentando entre los países
miembros de la asociación de naciones
del sudeste asiático cuya reducción del
producto interno bruto rondaría el
37,4 por ciento en un caso extremo
louis se ha logrado mitigar los efectos
del calentamiento global por ejemplo en
la reducción de gases de efecto
invernadero
lamentablemente a pesar de los esfuerzos
que muchas naciones han desarrollado
para ajustarse al acuerdo la situación
no deja de ser preocupante debido a que
muchos organismos no perciben una
reducción en torno a las emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero de hecho de
acuerdo con lo anunciado por el
secretario general de la organización de
meteorología mundial de las naciones
unidas las concentraciones de gases de
efecto invernadero batieron récord el
año pasado y que pese al confinamiento
producto del brote de kobe 19 la
situación no tuvo un efecto perceptible
en los niveles atmosféricos de gases de
efecto invernadero pero escuchemos que
otras cosas nos dijo el secretario
general del organismo
en este momento estamos en una posición
en la que podemos tomar una decisión qué
tipo de futuro nos gustaría ver a partir
de ahora por cidaut resources si
continuamos usando los combustibles
fósiles de manera ilimitada podríamos
alcanzar 4 grados de calentamiento al
final del siglo min
y si tenemos éxito con la mitigación
podríamos incluso limitar el
calentamiento a un cómodo nivel de 15
grados con foto por wang pueden
fabricarse louis hemos hablado de la
economía en el futuro pero actualmente
se está viendo afectada la actividad
económica por los efectos del cambio
climático en líneas generales sí y hay
muchos casos puntuales pero nos
referiremos a dos en particular uno
tiene que ver con la afectación de la
producción de miel en la región de
sicilia italia una situación que ya fue
expuesta acá en france24 para tener un
ejemplo la producción de miel podría
caer en esa región alrededor del 70% y
estamos hablando que es la segunda
región con la mayor cantidad de colmenas
dentro de italia en la gráfica vemos que
en 2010 se produjeron en italia 30 mil
toneladas de miel en 2023 en 2000 en
2015 en este caso 23.000 toneladas y en
2020 17.000 pero en la región se tiene
un caso preocupante y estamos hablando
de américa latina y que tiene que ver
con la reducción del río o del nivel del
río paraná este cuerpo de agua es una de
las principales fuentes de ingreso de
sudamérica y debido a la situación
incitando un trabajo de la publicación
de new york times en español el n ha
elevado en los costos en los viajes
desde los 15 mil a los 35 mil dólares
diarios al tiempo que el costo de
exportación de productos agrícolas desde
argentina se elevó a 315 millones de
dólares en el período comprendido entre
marzo y agosto esto según los cálculos
de la bolsa de comercio de santiago
louis muchas gracias por la información
económica de ustedes también muchas
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
i
[Música]